let's look at new year's resolution so
it should we and you're bound to have
made some where you stick to them
probably not because we don't do we but
what about doing more exercise in 2016
that can't be a bad thing can it well
perhaps it could be health experts are
saying that if we sort of going for this
extreme exercise you could do yourself
more harm than good we're enjoying
ourselves more and more it would seem
let's talk to at triathlon runner and
physio Julia made good morning morning
look you know this from both sides and
if you're quite athletic and a physio as
well well what mistakes are people
making well I think the big problem is
that people are getting good ideas about
improving the amount of exercise that
they do and obviously for the health of
the population that's something that we
want to encourage and not to diminish
people's want to try and join in things
there's a massive growing sport of
triathlon with lots of events
encouraging people to take part so like
super sprint distances which you can
literally come in off the street and run
and do one of them but people going into
them is kind of what we return weekend
warriors so they're spending a lot of
time at their desk sedentary jobs during
the week and then expecting at the
weekend to take on these massive either
endurance activities or put a whole lot
of effort in so it's the it's the sort
of expectation and pacing themselves to
achieve those things and yet if they
give themselves a little bit of an
injury does it really matter is it
something that you can easily recover
from are you talking about getting
injuries that actually could be
sustained well looking at most of the
injuries that occur in the triathlete
population they can be compared
generally to running related injuries
they mostly are less injuries and you
would get in the general runner
population but most of them sort of
around the knee lower back and ankle
injuries so when you think about like
shin splints these are all over training
and people going into a sport and trying
to sort of blast into it type of sports
people are taking off or is it the
amount of actually there's something I
take well I think it can be varied so if
you're in adequately prepared for
anything then you're going to struggle
with adapting your posture to
sustaining a position or running a
distance or swimming so people who are
coming in from a background where
they've been runners previously probably
a little bit of an advantage to those
who have been cyclists or swimmers
looking at the prevalence of injuries in
that population generally always
slightly diluted in how fit we are and I
used to run I used to cycle I used to do
all sorts of things but I can't do it
now I think it's about setting
achievable goals so making sure that
you're realistic with what you achieve
and building a adequate support
structure within your week so for
instance if today you've said I have my
goal is to do a triathlon of a short
distance this year really looking at how
you program your week so making sure
that you've got some core stability
exercises in there so as a physio we
really advocate the use of the core
stabilizers around the abdominal region
particularly around the pelvis and the
hip because a lot of injuries occur in
the lower limb related to the iliotibial
band which is sort of down the side of
your leg into the knee injuries and how
you work your muscles at the back of
your legs is really really fundamental
for these running type injuries lower
back injuries particular if you're
sitting in this posture at your desk
slumped down the whole time can really
be worked with Pilates which really
helps to sort of open things up well
strengthen I think Julie the message is
be prepared to do a bit of research and
don't just jump into it all em thank you
for joining us thank you i'll be in the
green room in about five minutes if you
get the towels ready and i'll have a
nice lovely